entre-temps il ya beaucoup de gens au
canada qu'au québec - aussi qui va
changer de gouvernement tous les pays
mais où
votre gouvernement minoritaire ben moi
je dis qu'on a reconnu les deux presque
rien mais on a toujours eu une position
pour mieux négocier
la dernière fois on avait
une proposition que les députés libéraux
de ses parents les avaient repris 80%
les propositions du bloc au programme de
coalition sont chères au gouvernement
minoritaire dirigé par qui serait le
meilleur scénario et du québec
merci est minoritaire moi je reçus
seulement m comment
locke pourrait s'allier
il était possible
ya présenté son budget de mai
nous on était sérieux dont dix aux
commentaires pas de budget a peur on
peut entendre de l'en-avant chiffres et
les options applaudi les observateurs
disaient suspect vivre il va provoquer
d'élections fédérales amen
j'ai été chercher trois points trop
d'argent son avocat reconnaît mais quand
je regarde ce qu'il a fait depuis qu'il
est majoritaire en france - avec un
dossier implose et c'est exploiter
libéraux de dixans oui mais pas pensé
vous êtes majorité de leur devant de
porte et je vois pas la possibilité de
choisir qui des données pour un vague
personne qui suit dans votre région
certains les québécoises c'est nul tout
doux pour moi je respecte le choix des
cannettes
choix des canaux gc ca démocratie qu'on
a n'a rien